Academy Award.
I still can't believe I'm standing here.
It's a dream.
Long time ago, every year when I watched Oscars with my dad,...
...sometimes with my mom, my dad always said...
..."Son, you got so many movies out around the world,...
...when are you gonna get one of these?"
Then I just looked at my dad, "Hahaha! Dad, I only make comedy action movies."
Many years later, I come to Hollywood, meeting with some big studio directors,...
...my friend's house, Stallone's house.
That was 23 years ago.
I see these little things in his house.
I touched it, I kissed it, I smelled it.
I believe you still have my fingerprints in them.
You keep it.
Then I talked to myself, "I really want one."
Finally, Cheryl called and I said, "Are you sure?"
After 56 years in the film industry, making more than 200 films,...
...I broke so many bones; finally this is mine!"
This is mine.